earlier this year I helped out the BBC
filming a company called Firefly in
Texas who manufacture Rockets engines
and lunar Landers this was specifically
a test fire of their Reaver engine and I
was fascinated to get an up close slo-mo
look of a test fire every test fire uses
a lot of resources and can't easily be
repeated so we had one attempt at this
today because of that I spent a lot of
time talking to some of the engineers
that worked there to try and figure out
the best position for the camera best
way to protect the camera and best way
to trigger the camera because obviously
it couldn't be anywhere near this thing
when it fired but thankfully they had a
housing large enough to cram the camera
in the area around the camera would be
subjected to intense heat and vibration
so we made sure to seal the camera in
there as much as possible and then
protect the cables coming out the back
of the box when filming a one-off event
like this rocket test fire or for
example a huge explosion I always find
it useful to ask as many people as
possible how bright they think the
explosion or fire will be and that's
actually quite a difficult thing to
quantify or put into words what I wanted
to see was detail in the flame but
without making everything else in the
image completely black so I was trying
to find a nice middle ground in one of
the emails I was told to expose about 40
darker than I would typically I ended up
under exposing the image much more than
40 I went about four stops under and as
you'll see from the footage I probably
should have gone even further than that
after all my settings were in we had to
clear the area about an hour before the
test fire but thankfully the test fire
was a success the camera triggered at
the perfect moment
here's a lovely slow-mo footage here we
go the White Cloud you see here is
oxygen one of the two propellants this
is done to condition the liquid oxygen
to ensure that it's at the desired
temperature and density the propellants
being used here are liquid oxygen and
rp1 which stands for Rocket propellant
one very common fuel in liquid rocket
engines it's basically a highly refined
kerosene more so than typical jet fuel
the green flame shooting out is trieth
aluminum
triethyboron also pronounced t-tep it's
a fluid that combusts when it comes into
contact with oxygen slash air I love the
fact that this initial puff of flame is
lingering in the air because it's a
great medium to see the shock waves
caused by the engine ramping up
as the thrust is increasing you can now
see Mac diamonds appearing in the
exhaust the spisonic flow of exhaust gas
and the shape of the nozzle essentially
causes standing shock waves that appear
in this diamond formation the orange
flame is an indication that the
combustion has started between the main
propellants as the power ramps up the
rp1 and liquid oxygen Burns so bright
that you actually aren't able to see the
Mac diamonds as well but they are there
for the entire duration of this one of
the unique things about Firefly is they
use a tap-off engine cycle which
eliminates the need for additional
combustion Parts which makes it more
reliable lighter and cheaper to produce
now at full power if this was in a
vacuum the engine would be generating 45
000 pounds of thrust the temperature of
this combustion is close to 5500 degrees
Fahrenheit around 3040 degrees Celsius
the fact that I underexposed the scene
so much that it effectively looks like
night time and the flame is still blown
out gives a great indication of just how
bright this actually is this Reaver
engine uses a turbo pump the job of the
turbo pump is to take the stored low
pressure propellants and then massively
increase the pressure before sending
them to the main combustion chamber this
increases the thrust and efficiency of
the engine
I think the most insane thing to me
about this footage is that you could
look at this and not necessarily know
this was at 2 000 frames a second this
is 80 times slower than real time and
the only indication is when these little
pieces of debris are flying past the
camera the flame and the vibrations
produced by the engine look so
incredibly fast it could almost be real
time all in all it's a pretty
nerve-wracking experience but I'm really
excited about the footage we got I want
to give a big thanks to Firefly for
letting me have such great close-up
access to this test fire and also
providing me with all the information
about what's happening in the slow-mo
footage and also a big thanks to the BBC
for letting me know this was happening
and allowing me to come along and meet
all the people at Firefly hopefully you
enjoyed this video let me know if you'd
like to see more rocket themed videos in
the future
thank you very much for watching